good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday hope
everybody's having a great day I know I
am because
hmm because you like it
because
I like it
yeah that's right that's reason enough
for me to be having a great day Jackie
that's beautiful thanks but I'm so glad
you're having a great day it's a
beautiful day outside it's a beautiful
Monday we had a beautiful weekend I got
lots of turdy Lou time you did you did
you dead and for that I feel blessed
yeah it was kind of like an amazing
weekend I didn't not that this should be
like revolutionary but I didn't drink
um which just makes the weekend so much
longer yeah when I woke up on Sunday I
pretty much I thought it was Monday and
I'm like and
but it wasn't it was Sunday yeah and
then we had a nice girly swirly day yeah
we have girly swirly day Saturday and
Sunday like I came over to your house
Saturday I did go to zabar it's just
like a you know quick update from
Friday's episode
um I did get like a lot of backlash from
the New York Community being like Elise
is it day bars okay so like God shut up
zabarz is like the original one location
on the upper west side and then like
different members of the Zabar's family
opened like grocery stores restaurants
okay guys Marketplace Eli's Essentials I
do agree with that because there is like
zabars and that zabars and like you were
taken in by Eli's world yeah but I think
you can colloquially call it zabars
without the pitchforks
yeah without being attacked yeah I think
that's a little extreme but I do know
what they're saying because Zabar's is
different than like what we saw and what
we were so taken by no but like they're
all like the same
yeah yeah well you brought me a bounty I
thought you were saying you were got
backlash from your haul because you did
a little Tick Tock haul so I went to
Zabar's before I went to Jackie's
apartment on Saturday me and Ben just
like Ben was Ben also like classic New
Yorker I'm sure he's been to Zay bars
but really until I opened his eyes to
like the magic of it he was kind of you
know moving through life not even
thinking about say bars and now it's all
we think about yeah how are you gonna
get Ms a bars where can you go that's a
close to his a bars so you can work in a
trip to Xavier you know our our lease is
almost up and like we are heavily
thinking about moving near a zabars or
an Eli's location
um but on Saturday like I wanted to
stock my house with delicious treats but
then I was also going to Jack's house
and I'm like you know this pregnant girl
needs this delicious food the Bebe needs
this delicious food as we're calling him
Larry little Harry he needs Larry needs
sourdough Larry needs these cookies so I
went so horde I spent and by the way
when I went to the zabars just during
our doctor's appointments on Friday I
just picked up like a bagel and a bottle
of water like I remember getting two
Bagels two waters and a muffin and it
was 19 and I was like I was unfazed by
the 19 you know in this climate
inflation ice cream is ten dollars I was
like all right I didn't even blink I'm
like okay 19. then me and Ben are
parading through the store for like the
first 15 minutes we are throwing
everything in our cart and then we get
to these delicious organic homemade jams
and Ben decides to look at the price of
something I'm like oh yeah we should
probably like see what the vibe is here
Jam
30 dollars
thirty dollars for [__] Jam
and that's when we kind of took
everything in our cart and we're like
looking at all the prices and we did put
some things back but some of the
essentials I was like you know what
we're paying for the experience and I I
figured
you know maybe Jackie will pay me back
for the stuff I'm getting her and like
it won't cost as much
um she did not pay me back I would never
it was a gift it was a gift it was a
gift okay it didn't occur to me but I'm
happy to pay you no no it was a gift I
stand by my gift I'm not like that at
all
um I'm just I'm simply not it was just
very jarring and so you know people on
Tick Tock are always talking about
arawan in La I've actually never been to
arawan but it's similar it's like an
upscale grocery store it's supposed to
be like for the essentials and like a
water bottle is 15 and I just figured
that those people need to know about
zabars where a jam is 30 and a box of
cookies is 25. yeah but I feel like I've
been to an Erawan before and I do feel
as though you're kind of paying for the
name and the experience and like some
hoity-toity like value set whereas at
daybers like you're paying for a loaf of
bread like you're paying for sustenance
and you're getting food I feel like at
air one you're not getting food you're
just getting vibes
that's true I have to say though I
really can't blame a business owner for
hiking their prices up during this
economy like if anything it's their
right and you know I felt good about
supporting the economy like I'm just
trying to put a positive spin on it you
know yeah no and I've been loving my
Bounty I had some bread this morning I
had sourdough and eggs how good is that
bread so good it's like really inspired
me to want to make more sandwiches I
actually was going to do like a call out
on my Ig story like what are some good
sandwiches for pregnant ladies because
all the good ones we can eat like a
turkey like with deli meats you know oh
that sucks so I need to get creative and
make some sandwiches before the bread
goes bad
yeah I had a sandwich last night too
delicious grilled cheese and I really
love that's what I was saying to Ben I
don't really love sandwiches but that's
because I don't really like like sweaty
meat so most people will have like a
turkey sandwich a pastrami sandwich I
don't like what other sandwiches are
there I pretty much eat peanut butter
and jelly and grilled cheese which is
like kids menu I like a tuna sandwich
can't have it hate but yet no that's why
you need to like have the caprese or
something ugh I know
so I like love the concept of sandwiches
like I think if somebody were to be like
let's have sandwiches I would say yes
let's but in actuality in execution I
don't really like know what sandwiches
are there for me why can't you have a
turkey sandwich you love turkey
I do love deli turkey like that you can
like roll up and just pop in your mouth
but not like in a sandwich well that's
because you don't like lettuce and I
don't like the accoutrement and you need
it you can't just have turkey on bread
it's too dry right you need mustard
lettuce pickles and you don't [__] with
any of those things
I do not that's why you don't see it you
see this predicament I found myself in
with my big loaf of sourdough yeah but I
think you'll find your way out
one thing about me like I'm gonna figure
it out yeah she perseveres that turdy
and then speaking of persevere and
something really kind of difficult that
I experienced this weekend that was
really hard for me on Sunday I woke up
alone Ben was golfing whatever and I was
like you know what
I was bored so I'm gonna I'm gonna take
myself out to lunch and I brought my
Kindle and I was like so excited and I
was going to your house afterwards so I
figured I really needed to bring Theo
with me because I didn't want to leave
Theo home alone all day and he should be
able to see Bruce whenever he wants like
I took
Theo to lunch with me at a restaurant
that I always see dogs at so I know it's
dog friendly they didn't give me [__] at
all they were totally nice but my God
Theo is not a restaurant dog I see like
other dogs in restaurants and they're
just laying at the owner's feet like
sleeping being so sweet
Theo did not sit for one moment there
actually came a point he was on the
leash under the table I was just trying
to just keep him under there there was
one point where he fully barked and I
was humili I was in bed Asado in the
actual meeting oh no in the actual
meeting is pregnant in the English
meaning yeah shadow
let's stop that your boy did that to you
he was jumping up on the table so then I
like put him in my lap and I was like
sit down and then the lady came over
she's like I'm really sorry you can't
have the dog up on the booth and I'm
like you know what that's fair that's
quite just literally disgusting so I put
him back on the floor I ate my lunch so
rushed I didn't even get to read I was
eating my wrap with one hand and like
caressing Theo with the other giving him
little bits of lettuce so he would just
shut up and I don't know at what point
like is it either you like have a dog
fit for restaurants or you don't is it
something that they learn well my theory
was that it comes with age like he's
just a little too young and excited to
be in a restaurant but I think some of
the older dogs can handle it better
better but I also think that there are
just dogs that are trained for
that sort of environment and Theo's not
no and there are also just some dogs who
aren't like hungry dogs like the reason
why Theo was being so nuts was because
he was hungry like Theo could have
literally accidentally gotten into his
entire 15 pound bag of kibble and he'd
still be hungry afterwards
yeah he doesn't say no to food and I
don't think all dogs are like that I
think some dogs like eat and they're
good and I don't know they don't I don't
think so just do all dogs literally
spend all day every night of their brain
power looking for food maybe like all
dogs except like Chihuahuas they don't
have like that much space you know yeah
but it's it's not the chihuahuas who are
chill at the restaurant by the way
you know the last time I went that
really inspired me I saw this enormous
golden doodle just like chilling
damn I don't know what it is maybe
people could give you tips I personally
have been thinking about and I'm not
gonna do it because like because I have
a baby so I think it's really silly but
I'm kind of loving like dog strollers
like when I see someone with a stroller
for their dog I'm so jealous like I know
that this dry sand would love it but
like how can I finagle like a real
stroller and a dog stroller no you can't
I'm sure they have like Duos yeah I'm
sure they do but also Streisand usually
goes in the undercarriage of the
stroller and he likes that but I usually
just don't walk with him and the
stroller because it's a mess but I feel
like if you got Theo like a little
houseboat for himself then he loves to
walk oh he loves to walk see stride
doesn't like to use those little eggs
no he cries when he walks he's like Mom
can we go back to bed yeah he just like
wants to be picked up yeah no he's
literally like meant for a stroller by
the way the way that you feel about like
jog strollers is the way that I've
started to feel I was having this
conversation with Ben and he was like
those are disgusting I can't believe I
think that leashes for kids is the
smartest idea and they're not leashes
it's not like a color around the kid's
neck yeah it's like a harness tether
yeah it's like a backpack because when
I'm I always like I have such sympathy
for like moms in the streets who have
like a stroller and then two toddlers
and the toddlers are running ahead and
you know there's cars there's street
lights there's pedestrian like laws that
kids don't know about I don't I don't
know if I'm gonna get canceled like if
and when I become a mom like I will be
tethering the [__] out of my kids to my
hips they could be running around these
streets yeah I don't think it's a bad
idea either it's good for the mom and
it's good for the kids and it's like
it's not around their neck like it's
like a backpack that you clip onto or
something yeah and I do see the logic in
it as well
no I think that like kid leashes need to
be rebranded because whoever gave them
like the name leash it's like well
you're gonna treat a human like a dog I
get it but there is enormous benefits
When I every day I leave the house I see
someone I'm like you know you need a
leash like when you have a stroller and
like you your job is the stroller but
then you have two little toddlers like
and the kids love to just run ahead run
ahead run ahead
no yeah and I don't think it's necessary
if you live in the suburbs but like when
I see kids walking these mean streets of
Manhattan it's so busy anything can go
wrong all it takes is a second I think
I'm gonna go on Shark Tank and I'm gonna
start like a business but we're we're
kind of taking back the power
tethers is tether bad like your children
should be Tethered to you yeah I think
tether is good
tether kid
you're a tether kid you should have been
a tether kid
I was the exact type of kid who needed
to be tethered and I didn't even live in
the city when I was at my like height of
but it's also better like when you're
taking your kids to the mall or like to
the airport like any Yes concert
honestly you should use it like for
friends like the buddy system like oh me
and you were going to a concert and we
don't want to get separated let's tether
ourselves I completely agree let's
hmm wow makes it makes you think makes
you think just a billion dollar idea on
a Monday morning
right and that's the kind of
um Ingenuity you can come to expect here
at the toast yeah and we never make any
of these ideas come to fruition so
they're kind of like open IPS and you
could pick one up and make it your own
at any time and we'll just be happy to
enjoy the product that we dreamed of no
and a percentage in royalty we're not
stupid oh really how can we ensure that
no we're just asking The Toasters will
give us the toasters whoever whatever
toaster one of these days decides to
take on one of the ideas
we spout here at the toast they will
give one percent to us and then one
becomes a multi-billion dollar company
we'll just be like raking in our one
percent in Turks and Caicos okay so one
percent free one percent for me
two each two and a half each and then
one for Bryce one for strikes because we
couldn't do it without them
oh so they literally inspired this idea
yeah but they literally don't have bank
account so I'm not about to like give an
honorary percentage to a dog when that
percentage could be mine yeah Bruno lost
all his money in crypto and he's like
not been okay ever since
ever since I've actually I've noticed a
shift I didn't realize he was going
through that yeah
of course and it's just
you can't take Magnolia to the Maldives
whenever he wants
you know I think it's actually good he
was like flying a little too high 100
every day asked me for five grand to
take nulls to the mousies I'm like what
the [__] do you guys do there
you say Bruno I haven't even been to the
Maldives literally
so let's talk shop let's talk what's
going on let's talk what's happening on
this episode and what's happening this
week okay so I know that you are like
using your bed rest for for good you are
watching The Real Housewives of New
Jersey and I think we should do like a
full recap but we haven't been keeping
up with this season I have like very
late though and I did Skip like three
episodes because I just couldn't yeah um
we have let's do that in the TV recap
okay because I am about halfway through
the season I'm I'm in Ireland there on
their trip it was a dark trip yeah oh I
guess they they just finished their trip
it's the season is so crazy I'm glad to
be watching it all together though
because like I don't have that many
thoughts episodically like I'm just
enjoying it and I also love the women I
also love the way that they've built the
cast now where it's like we have our
core cast but we have like probably
double the amount of people and just
like friends of and so when we go on a
trip there's just like so many people
and personalities and it's not like the
same we actually we do wind up having
the same conversations at every meal
about how Rachel right is a rat and as
an Arsenal every single meal we talk
about Margaret's Arsenal
um but other than it's like nice to see
like just fresh it's a cool Dynamic it's
not just the same five people like
Jackie's there and and they don't have
to do the most but they add a little
something so I'm really enjoying the the
season
so we'll do that in TV recap and then I
also want to talk about a show that I
watch that a lot of people recommended
um I'm only on episode three it's called
Love and Death on HBO math or excuse me
Max
and I think you would love it
and I want to talk about it in TV recap
okay I'll add it to my content plate uh
is it depressing
it's a good question it's like it's not
okay then then great but it's not it's
not like uplifting no I don't need it to
be Ted lasso I just feel like I always
go to watch a show especially like
fictional drama shows and like that
every single one is depressing like no
you can definitely set out to depress me
and I don't need uplifting nonsense I
just like want a regular regular [__]
show
so we'll do that and then this week I
got my schedule all together over the
weekend I'm excited so today we're doing
audio only if you're on YouTube
apologies
um Audio Only Jackson Claude and then
we're also doing Audio Only Jackson
Cloud on Thursday because we you know
we're had the foresight to realize
Wednesday night is Vanderpump Rules and
so we need to be together for the recap
on Thursday and then we're also going to
be together on Friday because Friday's
just like a special day for us so Monday
Thursday Friday is Audio Only Fridays in
general our special you're making it
seem like we have like a big thing on
Friday
Oh no just like you and I have like a
deep connection to the day Friday the
day of the fry yeah exactly and then for
Tuesday Wednesday we could have still
done Audio Only but you know me like it
department has to get a video up so
tomorrow we have just uh a check-in with
Taylor strucker which I'm really excited
to do because she's just been like
traveling on tour with stassi so we'll
like get the tea and she's just like a
great pop culture girl I loved and The
Toasters love her like that nothing
brings me more joy than like a regular
degular kind of one of our go-to
villains who people love like Margo Ben
and Taylor schrecker I know like we're
not gonna get hate for you know and then
Wednesday we have Joey camasta coming
back which honestly I didn't realize how
much of a movement there was within the
toaster Community to bring Joey back
Joey came on a year ago during your
maternity leave and then I think he was
on like a few years before that just
with you and I as a guest and he was
dazzled everyone and he has this new
life like this new career at Barstool
that has really just given him like a
new audience and I think the toasters
are gonna love the episode I mean I
haven't recorded it yet but I just have
a feeling it's gonna be great and they
were so happy that Joe is coming back
for Joey we're crazy crazy which makes
me I mean the last time he came on he
really was when he told the story about
shooting his pants in the Uber
if you haven't um heard that episode
like I highly suggest going back to last
maternity leave it was what may February
March March no because yeah we took off
February like we took off like from
February to March so it would have been
like late March or April
go look the 2022 episode with Joey
Master it's if you are unfamiliar with
his work in preparation for Wednesday so
I feel really good about where the
schedule is at this week I feel good
that like you're going to be here but
you're also going to get like you know a
couple of days off you just relax and
chill and eat sourdough sandwiches
literally to eat sandwiches so I feel
good I feel good that you feel good it's
a good balance of Jackson Claude and
also like Claude thirsting out in the
studio on camera being the snatcher
which she has to do like she looks great
and you gotta see her
and I forgot to tell you this but like
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday night of
this week oh that's literally today
tonight tomorrow and the day after I
have plans to get dressed and stay alert
all three nights at three Taylor
frequented restaurants do you know that
Wednesday night you have plans with
Margo
ashrae yeah
she was telling me you guys were going
to a concert and I was like oh I know
everything about Claudia's schedule and
she hasn't mentioned it
because I know your schedule
oh [__] I figured you forgot because I
hadn't heard about it
oh [__] did she get tickets yes she said
like I asked her what she was doing this
week and like that's what she's doing on
Wednesday she's hanging out with you
oh [__] me in the ass what plans did you
make
I was gonna go to dinner with
um this guy Blake I wonder if he listens
to the toast who Ben knows um through
Spritz and Ben was just like you'll
really like this guy
um like you guys are very similar he
like loves Housewives and then I went to
his Instagram and like all of his
pictures are just hanging out with
different Housewives so I was like I
have to meet this guy
um but [__] I think I might have to
reschedule I forgot I had concert
tickets or maybe you could like do both
dinner before the show or something yeah
yeah yeah
[__] oh I have to talk to Ben Ben hates
one I'm the worst on my calendar I
didn't realize it was June 7th already
yes me and Marco had concert tickets I
totally forgot yeah I figured you forgot
because it just sounds I went you had
dinner with her last night and she was
she was talking about it like the plans
were on yeah yeah because I was asking
her like what she has coming up this
week we had um pulled brisket sandwiches
together you did yeah we did
how was it I've been telling Jackie
because I got her these brioche
hamburger buns from zabars sandwiches
I know but I and by the way Friday's
episode being called Sam which thought
like today's episode should have been
called sandwich [__]
I put in our cart these brioche
hamburger buns and I was like you know
what I wasn't sure who they were going
to be for and honestly my my price like
my bill was already so high I couldn't
take two I'm like you know what I'll
give these to Jackie and it's been the
biggest regret of my life but she was
like I want to make a sandwich with the
brioche buns what should I do and I'm
like it's such a sandwich because it's
so it's such a bread for like a a wet
kind of Saucy meat that I thought pulled
brisket so you did it how was it it was
good but I actually didn't mind up using
your buns even because the buns from the
place that you told me to order the
brisket from were like perfectly good
and so I just didn't rearrange so I
still have the butter do you have any
extra brisket no
[__] yeah
but I could give you the Buns I still
haven't opened them
no like they're for you and I want you
to enjoy them like it would make me
happier if you would just eat them yeah
I need a sloppy joe
yes you do should I have been making
some and I'll bring it over yes that's
what actually that's like ruin a
surprise like me and Ben defrosted um
beef and I was gonna like make a vat of
chili and bring it to you and the second
we defrosted the meat Ben opened the
pack and it smelled like raw eggs like
it was like a bad thing of meat oh so we
that was like the plan was kind of
aborted I really appreciate the effort
um which is only at turdy's house do
those things happen
100 something about your kitchen is
cursed that's another reason why you
have to move no I know I think there's
like a Roga element in your kitchen that
goes around like
[__] food but I think that Rogue
element follows me from apartment to
apartment because all of my kitchens and
all the apartments I've ever lived in I
am unable to properly cook something so
it's me hi I'm the problem it's made in
the kitchen there's a little bit of like
Edge
to like meet
his stuff you know like sure it was Ben
it wasn't me I was literally sitting on
the couch yeah but like when the meat
arrived whenever you bought it
directly in the freezer oh
I don't [__] around with me yeah
oh my God I totally forgot about this
you need to go to a meat education class
I need to go to meatspin.com
[Laughter]
that's what I need to do you do I think
that's what I need to do
um
this concert just really like threw a
loop through my whole week I was
supposed to get dressed and say alert I
mean you don't have to go
no like Margo bought tickets and I told
her I wanted to go and it's do you know
who Noah Khan is yeah stick season and I
love her mom but it's the season others
and he's like really good and I've
actually been listening to his album a
lot
if I get too close like I should go I
should go and like this I don't know if
I told you this but like you know this
is my year of yes which by the way I'm
kind of crushing do you agree yeah
this is also like my summer of concerts
like I love concerts and I should just
go oh that's nice I I love a summer of
concerts I literally used to go
it's so fun yeah yeah it's so fun I'm
gonna go I'm gonna have to tell them to
reschedule the dinner Blake if you're
hearing this I'm so sorry yeah you could
always do another dinner like it's just
Noah can't be rescheduled
I know I don't think Blake lives here
that's the thing I think he like came to
town for a few days oh maybe lunch I'll
try to make it working maybe lunch I
love a lunch yeah lunch is good lunch is
really good just don't bring Theo
100 lesson learned
um okay well I feel like now we could
get into the stories
if we must if we wanted to
and I do do you
uh uh yeah sure Jackie their means to
you Jackie do you do you what's up what
ad is that
we I don't want to say the brand but
like like probably a year ago we got
like a six ad buy from like a very
prestigious brand and their copy was
just like a little cringe it was like do
you do you and I couldn't say it I know
but I'm trying to remember what brand it
was I think I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
forsake them on this platform and it was
just really hard for us to not say
because they supported us it's not hard
it's just hard for us to not say like do
you do daddy like no I was like do you
do you it's it's
trick it was a tongue twister it was
well I look forward to seeing what the
brands have cooked up for us today and
without further Ado about whether or not
you do you here are the fast five
stories that you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
Skylight frames just in time for
Father's Day with Father's Day coming up
are you ready to give the best gift ever
well give the Skylight digital photo
frame it brings Joy on a daily basis
watching the photo cycle and seeing new
ones coming is a thrill if you're not
able to visit your Dad much it's even
more of a reason that he'll love the
gift of a skylight frame it's a touch
screen photo frame that you can email
photos to and they will appear in
seconds no matter where you are so Dad
can see your favorite moments he'll love
it I feel like this is such a dad gift
and what's so great about it it's really
even though it's like you know a digital
photo frame it's really not hard to set
up like even the least tech savvy person
can figure it out and then you the kid
can take care of populating the photos
from your phone no matter where you are
it's a great way to feel close to those
that you love especially when you're far
away and it's a gift that the whole
family can enjoy anyone can send photos
to the frame anytime anywhere from
wherever they are it's a gift that keeps
family members actively in touch besides
displaying wonderful photos you're also
gifting a gorgeous frame that adds a
beautiful touch to anyone they have a 10
inch or a 15 inch touchscreen and it's
so fun to swipe through the photos and
use the tap and you can even tap the
heart button to let the sender know that
the photo is special to them so it's
interactive and it's fun to use they
have 100 satisfaction guarantee if Dad
doesn't love his Skylight frame they'll
offer you a full refund you could
pre-load it with favorite photos for a
special Father's Day gift surprise them
with photos that he didn't even know you
had with a special gift mode feature now
is a special Father's Day offer get 10
off that's up to 30 off your frame when
you go to skylightframe.com toast to get
10 off up to 30 off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com toast that's
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Lululemon so sickly Lululemon
shorts they were made to stretch flex
and support the infinite ways of working
out giving you the courage to LEAP into
something totally new and totally
unexpected so they have fabulous shorts
at Lululemon just in time for you know
sweaty crotch season which is it's not
even upon us it's here you guys and you
got to be prepared some of our favorite
shorts from Lululemon include the hottie
hot short which is the short with a
comfortable range of motion and a
flattering fit they allow you to Max
your stride so you can move freely with
confidence they also have the wonder
trade short which I love they're a short
with supportive stretch that also keeps
you dry so it's powered by everlux
fabric the Wonder train collection
manages heat and sweat so you stay
comfortable and stay focused the
material is sweat wicking and quick
drying which is so important in these
extremely toxic extremely warm times and
they have great shorts for women of
course but they also great shorts for
men so either as a Father's Day gift or
if the man in your life is kind of
struggling during these warm weather
times with like a sweaty undercarriage
check out the pace breaker short it's a
versatile short that's up to any
challenge the ultra lightweight fabric
means you can train move and stretch how
you want without the baggage each pair
of pace breaker shorts is designed to
Wick away moisture so all that's left is
your intention Secure Storage means you
can keep things close without feeling
them bounce around if you catch my drift
so all these shorts are available at
lululemon.com Lululemon is a brand that
you can trust when it comes to Summer
wear when it comes to athleisure and
workout clothes so get into the
Lululemon shorts at lululemon.com that's
l-u-l-ulemon.com thanks turdy Lou Lemon
it's Wednesday okay so let's get into
the stories first a story broke kind of
at the end of last week but Natalie
Portman and her husband Benjamin
millipede are fighting for their
marriage amid his affair with a 25 year
old okay this is like kind of crazy and
I can't believe like we know what's
going on she's so like private I
honestly couldn't even tell you the name
of her husband before didn't know she
was married yeah she didn't know any of
this but Natalie Portman and her ballet
dancer husband are bad Black Swan of her
I know paddling to save their marriage
after she discovered that he had an
affair with a 25 year old woman sources
tell page six they're told the pair who
married in 2012 separated last year but
managed to work through their
relationship woes now their marriage has
once again been rocked by revelations
that he cheated new photographs from
France suggest that the former ballet
principal dancer has been spending time
with glamorous young climate activist
Camille Etienne Greta not Greta friend
of Greta fog
fog A source told page six that they
have not split and are trying to work
things out Ben is doing everything he
can to get Natalie to forgive him he
loves her and their family so they're
like working through this but I guess
how old is Natalie Portman
uh she is
because I have a thought but I just need
to know her age 41.
okay and I'm assuming he's like around a
similar age
uh let me just confirm
milliped age
45.
okay so I really do believe like people
in relationships can like get their
infidelity I think that like it's really
hard but I definitely
respect anyone who tries to but there's
something different about like having an
affair versus having an affair with a
woman 20 years younger than you like
first of all it's gross second of all
like I just think it's like a even more
depraved level of Affair to go with
someone like so young and impressionable
and
I don't think that I would be able to
work through this is kind of my point
interesting I mean her being so young
makes it literally so much worse yeah I
don't know that I would be able to
either but actually this was a
conversation on real houses of New
Jersey an episode I was just watching
because Jen fessler like took a break
from her husband because he had an
affair and then they separated and they
got back together and of course like
Jennifer Aiden
and the women made like strong cases for
like you can work through it but I agree
yeah something about this I would say
get the [__] out of my face
right like there are certain
um Affairs that relationships like can't
come back from like kind of like you
know Tom and Raquel like it being the
wife's best friend like that takes it to
another level so like okay like [__]
somebody at work like that's kind of
like the the best if you know like just
a random when it's somebody like in your
circle like a friend or a neighbor like
that takes it to another level and I
think going with somebody 20 years
younger than you
add so much more insult to injury it's
so disgusting and I think it shows like
a a person like a characteristic and a
person I wouldn't want to be married to
you know yeah no you make a very good
point it it is different
it's like it's like you're looking for
something that that is never gonna find
you're never gonna find is no longer
there is no longer like who you are and
if that's like you what you want to do
with your life then this life is never
going to be for you right because the
whole point of a marriage with you know
with an equal is that you grow old
together so if you're seeking and
chasing youth then we have nothing to
discuss anymore you know yeah
look this is disgusting and the way like
I hate this man and I had quite
literally never heard his name
like good for Natalie for trying to make
it work it's clear that like she's
committed to making her marriage work
this isn't the first time that they've
experienced like a break or whatever
um so I commend the effort but like I
think some things are unforgivable and
I'm not saying that infidelity is always
unforgivable like I do think people can
work through them you have to be like
extremely strong yeah um but it's
reminding me a lot of the show that I'm
watching Love and Death which is all
about Affairs oh interesting so do you
feel more passionately about it because
of the show
no because in the show like you kind of
become obsessed with the two people
having an affair you know you're like
yes toxic it's so [__] it's so [__]
up
um but like in that situation the people
having an affair like they all know each
other so it's like a friend sleeping
with a friend's husband which is another
level of disgust yeah I agree this makes
it worse and I just can't believe that
we know this level of information about
someone who's like really so private I
guess it's like those French photographs
that like under it's always like the
daily mail out here telling us things we
really shouldn't know you like it's
giving Dominic West and Lily James
that was still such a crazy time in
American history that not enough people
like really cared about I kind of ship
now with a little hindsight no that's a
thing
that's the thing about Downton Abbey
is that once a character appears on
Downton Abbey they automatically become
my favorite character and he was in the
most recent movie and when I tell you
there was not an actor on this planet I
disliked more than Dominic West because
his character on The Affair was the
worst and then he did that Lily James
thing I was like this guy's [__]
disgusting and then he went on the crown
and and then he went on um Downton Abbey
and I kind of am obsessed yeah also the
crown even though he played persons
Charles like he did a really good job
with the show and he just became a part
of the cast and the history and like
yeah I turned a corner is he on the
final season or they go they go to an
older Charles now
I don't know I feel like he is because
this season is like about Diana's death
yeah but it's also like William and Kate
have you been seeing all those images oh
yes I have yes yes it has to be someone
older yeah they can make him look older
I know but they like to graduate
that's like my favorite and least
favorite thing about the crown that like
you fall in love like the way I [__]
loved Olivia Coleman as a queen and this
new girl is not doing it for me most of
the time when they replace someone you
love like you still fall in love with
the next person like they really do a
very good job but Olivia Coleman was a
tough loss for me
I didn't feel as strongly about Olivia
Coleman I liked Claire Foy and I do feel
like Imelda Stanton who's a new Queen
like she's getting a lot of hate and she
well yeah she got like people because
she's also from Harry Potter Lord of the
Rings or something and so she's like too
recognizable
as something else and she's playing the
queen in her flop era and I just think
the odds are stacked against her and I
want to support her that's true but I
remember like loving Claire Foy when I
first started watching the crown and you
were like by the way I was like binging
it late you were like the next two
seasons she's not in like they do this
thing where they you know cycle out
characters and I was so upset and then
immediately I loved Olivia Coleman so
it's like I'm open to loving but she is
not doing it for me okay
okay well I don't know if she's I feel
like she's in the next one too
even Philip like I did not want to give
up on Matt Smith like I but the next guy
they got I'm like you know what he's
Tobias Menzies was good and then also
you know the guy from Game of Thrones
shame oh excellent the shamer he's
excellent
shame but that by the way that's like
another oh no in Ted lasso Rebecca's
assistant you know Rebecca's the shame
woman
oh right
I didn't know that wait wait what no
she's not no Claudia I think she is
pulled from the West End she's like a
Broadway London girl Claudia I'm pretty
sure she is the woman
yeah Google it you're at your computer
oh no I believe you I believe you you
have to see her in her shame Garb okay
hold on hold on
Rebecca waddingham no not Rebecca what's
your name Hannah wanting him actually a
Game of Thrones
oh
oh my God it's literally her
I don't believe
oh my God okay that changes well what I
was gonna say about Ted lasso is her
assistant like that you know funny
British chubby guy he's Sprout yes from
game down to Debbie yeah
I just love this little circle of like
British characters you know yeah love
Sprout I cannot believe that Rebecca is
shame
that this is like as mind-blowing to me
when I found out that Tom wamscam is Mr
Darcy yeah I agree
wow her versatility
is unmatched unmatched
well I mean that woman was
[__] horrible Game of Thrones like
the most evil [__]
oh my God I'm in shock I'm in chalk yeah
I'm sorry she even got another roll
after that wasn't just Typecast because
she was so compelling
[Laughter]
holy [__]
before our next story
I guess I'm just still kind of digesting
this news I know sorry I didn't mean to
like blow your mind this morning no it's
so important to know facts like that it
is especially at the toast like we live
for facts like that we live for facts
like that our next story someone else is
responding to being Typecast in one way
or another Ryan Gosling responds to the
criticism that he's too old to play Ken
and Barbie so Ryan goslinger
um and he's clapping back at the trolls
who have a problem with him being cast
as Ken not him calling me a troll I'm
giving like valid criticism I don't
think trolls is his word to be fair so
he did an interview with GQ this week
and he would he said I would say you
know if people don't want to play with
my Ken there are many other Ken's to
play with he said that he thinks this
discourse is funny given that people
didn't think about Ken before he was
cast but suddenly it's like no we've
cared about Ken this whole time no you
didn't you never did you never cared
Barbie never [__] with Ken that's the
point he said if you really ever cared
about Ken you would know that nobody
cared about Ken so your hypocrisy is
exposed this is why his story must be
told
okay
alternate headline to this story Ryan
Gosling is deeply unwell does that even
mean I don't know if this is like a joke
question mark question mark
first of all it's like not that deep
Ken's story needs to be told this
honestly sounds like a satire of What
actors say you know yeah like an SNL
skit yeah
wait what read it again
read it again
he said
Suddenly It's like no we cared about Ken
this whole time like because he said
that he didn't think people cared who
was going to play Ken before that he
said no well maybe it wasn't a priority
because we were all obviously like who's
gonna play Barbie because like women are
more interesting and it's the Barbie
movie so maybe yeah he wasn't like a top
priority but we just assumed they
wouldn't [__] it up yeah he said
although No One Believes although he
believes no one cares about Ken he
admitted that he feels like his that
he's the character's representative he
said quote I care about this dude now
I'm like his representative Ken couldn't
show up to receive this award so I'm
here to accept it for him oh my God he's
really lost his [__] mind I felt like
you know I think one of the things
everybody loves about Ryan Gosling is
he's so not Hollywood like he doesn't
you know go out we never see pictures of
him and Eva Mendes like he's so private
I feel like he has a really normal life
and he doesn't become one of these like
La Hollywood actors with like their head
so far up their own ass but he kind of
sounds like he's just like a part of the
Hollywood Machine this is like next
level stupid where he's just like taking
the parody of it all very seriously like
I feel like this whole movie is a parody
and like
I don't know he just went down there
like in response to criticism he's just
like went down a clown's path and right
and it's a path you know it's a choice
it is a choice and I respect a choice
being made I just want to say yeah
instead of like him Keeling over me like
I am old I am wrinkly no here's the
thing what's so interesting is like to
me they could not have cast a more
perfect Barbie like I don't know any
woman in Hollywood who could do it as
good as Margot Robbie and she in my mind
is not too old but literally I think her
and Ryan Gosling are the same age yeah
they're like in the same generation you
know I feel like when they cast her I
wasn't I didn't think it was the best
choice
no I remember being like duh who's the
Barbie of Hollywood
I don't know
well honestly like maybe Sydney Sweeney
now but like you know what I mean yeah
actually we've been talking about this
movie for years I know and it's still
like confounding because it's not out
yet no one knows what it's about and
they just like they released another
trailer okay
and it's what we thought like she has to
go to the experience the real world to
like be her best Barbie yeah it's like
similar to elf she gets like this
Challenge from Kate McKinnon she's like
you can either keep wearing the heels or
then gives her a Birkenstock or
experience the real world
cringe but okay
I like the premise of Elf I just don't
like that
she goes to Manhattan like she gets
arrested Ken goes with her like there's
another trailer
okay so it's Enchanted
it's Enchanted that works for me it's a
proven formula
it's a proven formula it's not out yet
we still don't like know if this movie's
gonna be good but I have to assume it's
gonna be good Margot Robbie doesn't like
do bad movies I don't know she just did
that other one that no one talked about
Babylon which
you're right David O Russell where like
Taylor Swift was in it for a second
right Brad Pitt everyone was in it yeah
why did anybody talk about that because
it was bad
interesting yeah
it's not as good as Babel
no it's not nothing is
are you ready for our next Story the
aforementioned Sydney Sweeney is sat
down with Sunday today to talk about how
her grandparents feel about her nude
scenes on euphoria
you know it's a good question
Sydney Sweeney says her father and
grandfather walked out when the family
watched Euphoria I should hope so
he said her family was a little shocked
when they first saw her Euphoria scenes
in an upcoming interview with Sunday
today she revealed that her dad and
Grandpa weren't properly prepared to see
her on the gritty HBO show which often
features nudity and sexual content in
fact she said the two of them actually
walked out the first time they tried to
watch it she said that her mom had
visited her on set a few times so she
knew the story my dad didn't I didn't
prepare him at all so he decided he was
going to watch it without telling me
with his parents she said my dad and my
grandpa turned it off and walked out
however she added that her grandmother
who she describes as a big supporter of
hers wasn't as fazed by the content and
didn't follow their lead she said she's
a big fan of mine I bring her all over
the world to my different sets and I
make her an extra so she's like totally
down with nude sick no I mean
grandfather and father like absolutely
not and her family should have done a
better job of making sure that they
didn't watch it like I know you've never
even seen Euphoria no I haven't so I
don't know I know that it's like nude
and stuff but I don't know what her
level of like participation is next
level there's literally Jackie a scene
where she's on a carousel at like a
carnival and she's like dry humping the
Carousel and she like has an orgasm in
front of all these people like that's
not even the worst of it because she was
fully clothed there's another one where
she's like [__] Nate in the bathroom
and they literally like the the camera's
just like on both of her breasts like
it's insane
I mean that's crazy but it's also like
and she should have told her dad and her
Grandpa yeah I do often think when like
you know starlets get men and women but
it's always the women who are naked when
they get like famous
um and they're in like these sort of
nude roles like how do they protect
their you know peace with like their
family and everything and Euphoria is
another level it's like even it's
probably the most graphic show on TV
when it comes to sex like I think
actually no hands down it is it's not
the most and I think now the idol is
gonna use sir which is the same Creator
yeah
the idol is such an interesting show
um there's been so much hoopla around it
the reviews are abysmal yeah
it looks and so graphic and pornographic
and and disturbing that's the thing
about Euphoria it's not only graphic
it's really the characters are supposed
to be teenagers so it's just even more
disturbing the actors are not but the
characters if you're you know buying
into the show these are literal
teenagers
um it's really uh dark and that's that
guy's thing Sam Levinson and it's really
like it's disturbing
yeah
I don't watch I don't think I'm gonna
watch I mean I'm not gonna watch the
Idol because I imagine it's disturbing
but even just like the still images like
they just look
disturbing disturbing but I think that's
gonna eclipse
Euphoria make a Euphoria look like
Child's Play
yeah but I don't think the idol is going
to be as popular as Euphoria that's the
thing interesting
like Euphoria is like the number one
show in the country
when it's on and it's not coming back
for like another year and it's been off
for a year
um yeah there's not much on right now no
and it's important that like you know
the young people who are watching
Euphoria while this time is you know
while they're off the air that they
watch you know more uplifting things
more educational things or maybe they go
outside cat dog
cat dunk Rugrats
such a good show
Rugrats is on Hulu for whoever wants to
know for Harry yeah because I was like
looking for kids stuff because you set
me up with my new TV and like Hulu was
the only thing I was logged into so I
went to the kids they had like five
shows and Rugrats was one of them how
fabulous is that yes so we started it
from the beginning it's like kind of
crazy it is a crazy show
like really that plot you just really
never know where it's no it's like it's
they're always being babysat by the
grandpa who's always sleeping and like
there's an actual
infant like running around in his diaper
who changes it so you're saying so
you're saying it's more so a show about
neglect yeah
and just like kids raising themselves
which is a powerful message but they
also are learning lifelong skills
friendship right right
Adventure that's beautiful that's
beautiful that's what I've surmised
because before I've watched 10 minutes
of it the other day I couldn't tell you
what Rugrats was about even though we
watched it every day yeah like what is
it about like I know SpongeBob is about
you know a sponge who lives in a
pineapple under the sea yeah and he's
like just trying to make his way through
the world he has a crabby neighbor he
has his best friend he has his job and
he's just living yeah he's like he's
like a working class guy yeah he's a
working-class citizen doing his best and
trying to keep it positive
that's beautiful yeah
but I couldn't tell you really the plot
of Rugrats
no you're 100 right maybe it's better
that way
yeah the mystery and cat dog
so I think it's about like a cat and a
dog who are conjoined at the hip and
just getting through life as as that
what's the larger message like that I
think the larger message is like
coexistence working together putting our
differences aside I'm a cat and then and
it's also just like you know getting
through life with the cards that you
were dealt you know I'm sure being
attached to a dog as a cat and being
attached to a cat as a dog isn't ideal
and we're all kind of given things in
life that aren't ideal but we persevere
just like CatDog did so it's a story of
perseverance
I would say
Claudia that's beautiful
cat dog cat dog theme song
that's no Mickey Mouse no but the cat
dog theme song like did slap yeah and
what would you say is the theme of
Mickey Mouse like what is he trying to
espouse
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse honestly I think
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse really does it
like an unrealistic standard for
adulthood in children because Mickey's
life is like too good it's like he
always finds himself in these situations
but he always has the exact tool that he
needs you know it's like it's a little
unrealistic sometimes you're gonna be
dealt a challenge and you don't have the
tools to deal with it there's not you
know what's that thing called his
Oh Toodles
yeah like he just isn't always going to
have all of that you know is kind of a
crutch but I guess it's it's a show
about teaching preparedness I think it's
a show about problem solving
yeah and working with your friends
even though some of them are [__]
dumb
Beyond moronic and just like having to
be like the one in the group who's
always getting things done like it's a
good lesson for like you know one day if
you're planning a bachelorette party
like it's all gonna fall on you and
you're gonna have to Shepherd these
girls through the trip and you learned
it from Mickey Mouse Clubhouse yeah it's
kind of a story like a modern
bachelorette party story
[Laughter]
it actually is yeah like oh my God
Sarah's dehydrated what do we have in
the in the pack and we have liquid IV
like we have the tools
to hell yeah but there's always the
Mickey
there's oh Olivia is the Mickey yeah and
you're the same there's always
um
[Laughter]
I'm the Mary you're the Rhoda are you
ready for our next story if it's the
next story that's brought to you by
ZocDoc tis
you're extremely unlikely to find
quality medical advice in your group
chat but you can find it from a doctor
on ZocDoc so I think all of us are
victims of having some sort of medical
issue and trying to find a cause for
your symptoms on Tick Tock getting down
a rabbit hole then following
questionable advice from so-called
experts you can avoid all the trauma of
that when you go to ZocDoc when someone
is just exceptionally good at what they
do it could be a waiter a chef a doctor
you know you're in good hands so find
the best doctor doctor on ZocDoc it's
the only free app that lets you find in
book doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance and are available
when you need them and they treat almost
every condition Under the Sun so there's
no more Dr roulette or scouring the
internet for questionable reviews with
ZocDoc you have a trusted guide to
connect you to your favorite doctor that
you just haven't met yet so with ZocDoc
there are no alarms or surprises you can
choose from thousands of patient review
doctors and Specialists browse doctor
profiles upload and verify with your
health insurance information and get the
care you need so whether you just moved
and you don't have any doctors or you
have like a new issue that requires a
new specialist I'm always discovering
new issues in my life and like I have to
go to like random doctors I've never had
to go to before ZocDoc is a Haven for
that go to zocdoc.com toast and download
the zoc Talk app for free then find and
book a top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that ZocDoc
zocdoc.com toast
zocdoc.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by Honey Love the reviews are in and
honey love came out on top for the best
wedding day shapewear with wedding
season upon us this is the ad you've
been waiting for whether you are a bride
a guest or looking for an everyday fit
Honey Love Is Your go-to for all things
shapewear honey love has revolutionized
compression technology so you no longer
have to feel like you're suffocating
while wearing effective shapewear you'll
immediately feel and see the difference
and we have an exclusive listener just
just we have an exclusive offer just for
our listeners get 20 off your entire
order when you go to honeylove.com toast
that's honeylove.com toast I'm a
shapewear expert I've been wearing
shapewear literally since I was like
eight going to Bat Mitzvahs and I've
been through such a journey when it
comes to shapewear whether it's
shapewear that doesn't fit shapewear
that does fit but doesn't let you
breathe the shapewear that digs shape
where that rolls down I found Honey Love
on literally I think Facebook five years
ago and it is my go-to for shapewear and
I've gotten so much feedback from
toasters ever since we started working
with honey love that have bought it for
weddings or work conferences and they
say it's like it's the real deal I
should have listened to you long ago so
they're super power short is helping
ladies everywhere sculpt and smooth from
stomach to thigh by offering just the
perfect amount of compression it really
is like a a delicate balance you want to
be sucked in and smoothed out but you
don't want to like die of Suffocation
well they get it at Honey Love they also
have body suits with 360 degree bonded
compression that Smooths your tummy and
hips built-in bust support without
underwire it's shapewear that's
comfortable you've heard that right
again we have the best shapewear code
for you treat yourself to the best shape
around the market and save 20 off at
honeylove.com toast that's uh 20 off
when you go to honeylove.com toast
and welcome our next story like speak of
the devil because on Friday we were
asking the question where is Olivia
Rodrigo
um literally as we're recording this
girl is posting teasers pointing toward
a June 30th Revival yeah so Olivia
Rodrigo seems to have her some tricks up
her sleeves the driver's license
hitmaker quietly dropped another hint
that presumably points towards June 30th
as a date to write down so on Saturday
fans noticed that the Spotify canvas
that shows up when you listen to
driver's license on the streaming
platform has been updated and in the
clip art it now has her expiration date
for her license as June 30th 2023. also
her website released a cryptic countdown
calendar that launched on Friday
um that also points towards the end of
June for Seminary and she posted like a
sexy mirror pic and in the back was a
calendar with June 30th kind of circled
so it looks like June 3rd like you're
wondering where Olivia is June 30th
you'll find out
very interesting one um you know me I'm
obsessed with this like whole love
triangle and she did release this like
you know bombshell news like the next
day after the Sabrina Carpenter thing it
might have even been the same day like
yeah just interesting just interesting
yeah no I think interesting too
and this is like a very highly
anticipated second album like I don't
know you know the last time somebody's
first album became as big as hers did
and there's a lot of pressure and you
know kind of harks back to this age-old
conversation we've been having like
about Olivia Rodrigo being a one-hit
wonder if you will like I'm curious if
this album will live up to the first
yeah I imagine it is so much pressure
and that's what I was saying years ago
when we had this yeah Wonder
conversation because even when she was
in her sour era obviously she had more
than one hit at the time but if this
album doesn't
do what it needs to do she will just
always be remembered as a driver's
license girl hence a wonder I think
she's extremely talented and capable of
turning out another work of art and I
think she'll live up to her own hype but
I imagine she's quaking
no it's like kind of horrible to like
have had such success so early
and just that's that's always going to
be your benchmark you know you always
want to be doing better on the second
the third than you did the first the
second so that's like the that should be
the normal growth and trajectory of a
young Starlet pop star but to have
historic unprecedented success in your
first album is kind of like a blessing
and a curse a hundred percent
I don't know how you live up to that
hype I mean that first album is
literally it's
I can't remember the last time like an
entire nation knew every word to an
entire album yeah but I also think like
sometimes you get so hyped from
something like you might just be like
right time right place or it's just like
a song that like captivates the country
it's not like particularly good but it
just happens to like yeah move everyone
um and I don't think I think she really
is that talented so if she had that
talent in her for the first album then
there's no reason why her second album
won't be just as good no you're right
because like yeah driver's license took
over the world but then the whole album
did like the whole album was as good as
drivers and drives maybe better took
over the world but it was an amazing
song it wasn't just like you know Old
Town Road that was like a gimmick silly
you know and then she like followed it
up with an entire album of like bangers
like you're right she has the talent
it's not a question of like whether she
got lucky like those songs took off
because they were good yeah like it
wasn't just luck and that she's going to
have to try and duplicate so it's just
inside of her and she just needs to
write how she feels
she just needs to write out she feels
and I know she's been going through like
a lot because there was like the success
of the album then she had a boyfriend
and I don't think they're together
anymore so she's been through things
that she can write about yeah even when
she was like 12 she was writing about
things like getting ice cream at the
same place as Sabrina and I wrote a
whole song about that and it was a good
one it was a really good one from going
to the ice cream
no literally no I don't no I can get ice
cream as many times as possible and it's
always going to feel like a new
experience there's always a new flavor
there's always a new flavor there's
always a new ice cream shop I actually
on Friday night me and Ben went out for
dinner and then I got gelato which I'm
more of like a if there's two
ice cream places next to each other one
of them is a like American ice cream
one of them is a gelato like I will
always go American and that's just me
I'm a proud American I don't think
anyone would have thought otherwise from
you but I had delicious gelato on Friday
night like it was delicious and what
flavor did you get
one thing about me like I'm consistent
I'm a creature of habit so guess what
flavor I got cookies and cream
yes ma'am me too that's also my go-to
it's just like it's foolproof it's the
it's the superior flavor and anybody who
tells you otherwise is lying and stupid
like I like to try like oh I'll try the
birthday cake but I know I'm not
ordering it
you know what if I am it's so funny that
you say that because if I am gonna order
another flavor it's gonna be birthday
cake that's like my runner-up it's too
much like the sample size like when they
just put a little on the spoon for you
is like enough of it it's really sugary
and sweet you're right like it's
overwhelming and an ordinary woman
cannot take it on I can you're no
ordinary woman what do you think like
when you think of the best birthday cake
ice cream what do you think of Cold
Stone no mine's really Niche was it the
place by my house no
um no no offense that place sucks no
you're wrong for that
okay let me give you like another clue
it's not a chain it's like when when
Zach we asked him to heat up like to get
us ice cream from the freezer we went
and got ice cream that day we got like a
blue ice cream extras we got extras for
the freezer yeah so then that night we
wanted it so we were like can you just
get it from the freezer and so we took
it upon himself to like warm it up a
little to Plate it he put it in a bowl
like it comes in a tub leave it in the
tub and it was soup and so then he said
he's still fidgeting in the in the
kitchen like trying to get it to
refreeze like five minutes later we're
like where are you and he comes back
with a blue mouth with yeah
because he literally melted our ice
cream he ruined it and then while he was
waiting he like ate the rest and he was
like okay to try to get it to refreeze
and it's like nobody even asked you to
warm it up like I can wait five minutes
while it gets to the right temperature
we're so mad he did that oh he did that
with my McFlurry the other day
heated it up
yeah well at first because McFlurries
are not like meant to go in the freezer
because they're supposed to be like so I
was waiting for it to but I couldn't
even get the spoon out
so it's like you know what you could
heat it up
what it came back how long did he eat it
up for I don't know how long he heated
up for but it came back with like a
paper towel wrapped around it and like I
heard some crashes in the kitchen it was
it was like a tea and no I heard it
crashes in the kitchen because I guess
he tried to pull the spoon out which I
didn't ask like I just wanted like a
little bit softer just like
it is
he's just doing the most um his ice
cream okay just to finish my thought the
best birthday cake ice cream I've ever
had is from gabells
that roadside Shack near the place where
we went to Camp like it was so good yeah
roadside roadside ice cream that has
like a picnic table that also serves
Burgers like very like Mom and Pops like
chocolate shop from the 50s those places
have the best ice cream hands down in
America so true but I also think you're
hopped up on the vibes
our Vibes were so high we were like
vibrating up lightning speed like any
ice cream would have been euphoric no no
those were the days
no
okay agree disagree okay
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
yeah that happened so fast it did it did
and didn't because it's been an hour
right yeah right
um and it's not really a story just like
something that's a little [__] up
okay YouTube is playing three minute
long advertisements before first aid
videos and they've already been linked
to at least one death by the way I saw
them respond I saw people complaining
about this on Twitter and then like
YouTube support responded and was like
basically telling people to go [__]
themselves
after finding someone unconscious and
calling an emergency service a worried
bystander might turn to YouTube for a
reminder on how to perform CPR but the
site is running advertisements before
videos showing how to perform the
life-saving intervention the ads are up
to three minutes long and some are only
skippable after 30 seconds dailymail.com
found advertisements for grocery stores
and shoes delaying first aid videos made
by Hospital Systems paramedics and CPR
trainers advertisements can be
personalized depending on the video
consumed by users
um who really gives a [__] what you're
about to watch oh I'm sorry and then by
the way when YouTube responded to the
person on Twitter being like I tried to
like watch a CPR video and there was
this ad and it feels really [__] up
they were like well if you sign up for
YouTube premium you won't get any ads
they were like trying to sell their
subscription well what was their
response a woman in Germany died earlier
this year after her CPR was delayed by
her helper having to sit through 18
seconds of advertisements on the
platform like I could I mean there's no
way of knowing that she wouldn't have
died anyway but still but I can
understand why like it might have not
been top of mind for YouTube to really I
was like oh we shouldn't have
advertising sound like emergency service
via videos like
I I never thought of it but like now
that we've established it like if I can
take them down yeah like verified
hospitals Medical Services who have
their channels and make like sort of
preventative videos they should not be
subject to any sort of AD revenue and
like you're right it might not have been
something that they thought of
immediately but like now that people are
talking about it they should act
immediately yeah no and it's not even
about like oh you shouldn't make money
on the CPR it's really just about the
time like if you want to put like an
emergency you want to put a post role
video ad go for it but like those
seconds are crucial pre-roll or a
mid-roll is not cool it's like or
they'll show up and be like hi I'm gonna
teach you how to do CPR today so the
first step is
ad like that's [__] up yeah
so I just thought that was [__] up not
cool no that is [__] up and I I had
seen their response being like check out
YouTube premium for 15 a month I was
cackling it's like not funny but the way
that they're handling this is like so
poor yeah I feel like they'll eventually
get it right you know it's really not
that hard task the thing with YouTube
companies like YouTube similar to like
Google they're so ubiquitous it's not
like you're gonna go to Vimeo now and be
like how to do CPR like YouTube is just
so integrated into our lives like you
don't even realize like when you just
search for a video you're always going
to find YouTube It's
like they don't like this isn't gonna
stop user behaviors like they're just
too big yeah so which is why they could
just do us a solid
right but they're just like a company
that's like uncancelable almost like
they're too baked into our everyday no I
agree but like
it doesn't change their bottom line if
like how many videos are there even if
it's a thousand videos a thousand videos
don't have an ad
no but like one thing I'm the type of
person like if I can't figure out how to
do something like I am gonna google it
oh my God yeah every like stroller car
seat like house yeah they actually there
are a lot of brands that make really
good videos like um they should I try to
[__] put Harry in a [__] high
chair at a restaurant I swear to God I
needed an engineering degree it was so
complicated then it turned out that it
was broken it's like it wasn't me yeah
there was something weird
similarly like I'm literally my my I.T
Department we're just on YouTube like
every new piece of equipment that we get
for the toast or issue I'm having with a
microphone or a recording device I love
those guys those guys who put together
like these kind of like geeky nerds who
have like these channels being like
here's how to sync your camcorder and
your road Caster that I'm their number
one fan I love those videos yeah just
like sometimes they just take too long
you know yeah yeah of course of course
like or it's like how do I get
GarageBand to do this and it's like a
whole video an hour long video about
GarageBand it's like no you're not
looking in the right places because I
find that [__] in 30 seconds no I've
I've struggled and they also like on the
one hand they go too slow you know it's
like oh I know how to open my computer
and turn it off yeah yeah and like open
up GarageBand that's clearly where I'm
at already yeah no that's fair that's
such a fair critique but still all to
the good help people helping each other
helping others helping others is key and
that's what we learned
um from the past five today
from Rugrats yeah and the Fast Five
um let's do a little TV recap let's do
Jersey I'm really curious to get your
thoughts and the Jersey recap and then
the just TV recap in general is brought
to you by go macro in the face of
adversity and a fight for survival
against cancer a mother and daughter
took their love to the kitchen and go
macro was born Ned now they are
spreading the power of a balanced
plant-based lifestyle across the country
with go macro so the go macro bars are
available in 17 full-size mouth-watering
flavors and five kids flavors all go
macro products are certified organic
vegan gluten-free kosher non-GMO clean
and soy free they're made from a
combination of plant-based ingredients
that serve as a healthy and delicious
way to keep you fueled throughout the
day so if you have a food allergy or a
dietary restriction go macro also offers
three delicious nut-free flavors
including oatmeal chocolate chip maple
sea salt and sunflower butter plus
chocolate
so the go macro bars are perfect for
anyone in terms of dietary restrictions
and they're also just a great thing to
have in the house in your bag they keep
you full they're really delicious I like
that they get really creative with their
flavors because I think a lot of these
bars start to kind of taste the same but
go macro being organic and vegan and all
this stuff is you know gives you a piece
of Mind knowing that it's good they have
kids flavors so you can feed your kids
knowing that they're delicious and good
and good for you
um and we have a code of course we do
but they also have a new um flavor mint
chocolate chip so it's crisp mint meets
creamy chocolate for a cool Endeavor
that refreshes and soothes the soul the
mint chocolate chip bar combines 11
grams of plant-based protein with
Organic cashew butter and a touch of
peppermint for the chillest companion
wherever you go get your hands on this
delicious new flavor by going to go
macro.com using promo code toast for 30
off plus free shipping on all orders of
over fifty dollars that's go macro
g-o-m-a-c-r-o.com promo code toast for
30 off plus free shipping
great thank you so much turdy Lou I love
go macro you're welcome okay so real
houses of New Jersey I'm in Ireland so
I'm pretty much like halfway through the
season I'm starting by the way how far
Lauren is that house it's like not
glamorous oh I like it but oh but like
just because I like it and that would be
like a fun trip that's like my vibe
these days you know but like the house
looks like like haunted like it's like
bare and like Baron no I think it's nice
okay it didn't feel that way to me
what's funny to me is like when they
take they're in they go all the way to
Ireland they get all dressed up and they
take like a bus just to go to a dinner
where they have like salmon and wine and
then go home and it's like you can do
that in New Jersey I've actually never
the first night they got there no it was
like one of the middle nights of the
trip but and I've actually been never
been someone who like thinks like that
like because you know I just want to do
like the same things that I like to do
just in other countries
but like you came all this way but then
the next day they did do that like hen
party and they chased around the
chickens and stuff and so that seemed
more
um authentic I just like don't
understand why they chose Ireland like I
know dolores's man is Irish but like
isn't this trip like really for Teresa's
Bachelorette like it makes no sense no
it's so random but I don't dislike it
no me neither I actually I loved when
the OC housewives went to Dublin like I
love when they do something different
and I love like a knot and I feel like a
water situation because they're so
Italian they're like so like and they're
always going to like Jamaica Dominican
Republic like classic vacation
destinations for like the eastern coast
yeah but I I liked the setting you're
not gonna get me to knock it
no no I agree I like that fish out of
water like when the New York Housewives
went to Morocco like something so so
different yeah and we get to see
something like different and interesting
and culture shocking and the fact that
they're staying in a castle not like a
hotel in town like it's nice
yeah no I don't I don't disagree that's
that's fair
um so overall so give me your takes like
from start like the new girls give me
everything oh my God the new girls are
so hard to keep separate and like I
really wasn't even giving any of them
the time of day until like a few
episodes in when I established like my
alliances
um I really like Rachel Fuda like really
great head on her shoulders I can't
believe that she like started filming
this season with a three-month-old like
and she's just she's so like stunning
and she's so like stunning put together
a snatchler like I literally wasn't
shock
um I think her family is just so nice
and I just I like her rationale and her
way about her like and I also like she
has like a good head on her shoulder and
I like that like her inclinations make
her gravitate towards Margaret and
Melissa because those are my people like
they are team rational and
uh Teresa and Jennifer and bringing in
Danielle they are team like just like
crazy emotional like no senses made
sometimes I understand where they're
coming from and like why their emotions
are so high about stuff but Margaret and
Melissa just always [__] make sense
you know I know and to be honest like I
could never not be on that side of the
couch like I am so Margaret Melissa and
Jackie too and okay but by the way like
Jackie did not have a good season I know
she's not even a housewife but like she
really pissed me off like when she came
in so hot I don't even like Danielle but
like when she just came in hot like
being so rude and like it was clear that
like Jackie had just gotten demoted and
then this new girl comes in and has like
a higher position on the show than
Jackie and like Jackie was clearly just
like jealous and bitter and that was she
was being so mean girl for no reason and
I don't even like Danielle yeah for no
reason it was just like weird
um they didn't even know each other and
she was like would you please your
shorts out of the hamper like don't be
[__] rules so what does that mean did
they look dirty I think that her shorts
were wrinkly but they're jean shorts no
it was like she was just looking she she
didn't even have a chance to speak to
her and then when she was like at
dolores's house house to I think it was
to Rachel being like you're not even
looking at me in the eyes right now
she's just like so insecure about her
demotion that she's lashing out to like
make a statement be like look Bravo you
shouldn't have fired me and she's taking
it out on these two new girls and it's
not fair yeah no she's irrelevant and
the rest of the season she's just like
there as like a friend in a sounding
board and she contributes nothing to the
show except like Evan obviously is a big
part of the husband's crew and that's
why I'm glad that they like keep
everyone in the fold because we need all
the husbands and like I love like they
go have a party at Melissa's house and
they don't even need to invite other
people it's enough people it's like 20
people and you have a party yeah no I
completely agree and I think like Evan
is a great part and what's so funny is
like at the end of last season I had so
come around on Jackie I was like really
didn't agree with her being demoted like
I think she really laid it all out I I
had a full 180 on her and my God she
just came in like so wenchy yeah with
like jealousy and insecurity I didn't
like that also the whole conversation
about Rachel food is nose is probably
like the rudest and most [__] up thing
and like the fact that like nobody
stopped
throw stuff around and also because like
Rachel food is a beautiful girl and like
yeah you really couldn't insult her
looks if you tried no and she has like
she has it all going on she's got like a
big house the family the looks like she
I'm sorry like I hate Danielle no I hate
her the like I I was for the beginning
first of all I thought all the new girls
names were Jennifer and they were all
the same to me but it wasn't even that's
so crazy because Jackie I had the same
like I literally was looking for
Jennifer food on Instagram and I was
like oh I guess she doesn't have IG
that's funny yeah so and they just call
everyone Jen because like Jennifer Aiden
is Jen Jen fessler and so I was like Jen
Jen Jen
um so I didn't even like have a a care
in the world between Danielle and Rachel
and I really wasn't like trying to get
invested in who I care about more but
then the chips fell where they may and
Rachel you know came to the correct
conclusions and also Danielle is just
like she's kind of a caricature of a New
Jersey housewife like she is too much
and she talks such a big talk in her
confessionals like she literally acts
like she is Tony Soprano and then every
time she gets into a Converse
confrontation with the girl she cries
and she walks away and it's just about
like her brother it's not even about
like girl and Margaret's Arsenal and she
can't handle that conversation but she's
the one you don't want to mess with like
I think I'll be okay
so I was like wait what episode are you
on Ireland okay I need to just spoil
something for you if that's okay sure
so her whole gripe they talk literally
non-stop until the finale about Danielle
being so hurt that she said something to
Rachel and Rachel told Margaret and
Margaret and Rachel was like I wasn't
doing this as gossip I was quite
literally just telling a friend what
people were saying about about her like
that's it
Jackie she doesn't stop talking about it
till the finale and in the finale
Danielle is the one who sits down
Melissa Gorga and is like this is what's
being said about you
um I just wanted to tell you about like
this cheating allegation that's going
around about you so she literally does
the same exact thing in the final
episode that she's met at Rachel food
afford the whole season she just tells
Melissa something she heard you know in
the under the guise of like you know
wanting to be there for her and look out
for her it's so hypocritical no it's so
hypocritical and also like Jennifer
Aiden who I actually has my sympathy and
I and I do like like I feel like
oftentimes she's wrong in arguments and
like she gets too emotional and clearly
everyone like has an issue with her but
I do like her and I feel like she
doesn't do a good job of explaining to
Margaret like yes I forgave you and your
apology was heartfelt in that moment but
there have been aftershocks and like all
the time since that happened and it
makes me mad again like I feel like she
just needs to say that once like I guess
I forgave you but like now my daughter
wants to be a love therapist and like
and I would understand that hearing that
and being like [__] Margaret you know
yeah no I agree but like I also feel
like it's really important and she
doesn't do a terrible job at this like
Margaret is to blame sure but like so is
the man who cheated you know oh of
course no but the thing is it's
there's two things here one like the
cheating which Jennifer like had made
peace with at the time it's about her
kids and clearly her kids are suffering
but also it's like the fact that their
home life in general it's not so peachy
right now so we're all compounded it's
not good and like Margaret played a
small role in that and I know Margaret
feels bad because when she apologized at
that coffee shop last season like it was
real she was
seriously regretful and remorseful for
what she did so but I think that and I
understand wanting to move forward we
can't always bring up the past but I
think Jennifer doesn't do a good job of
explaining like it still affects her
every single day she's not a good
communicator she just like screams and
yells and gets drunk but then Jennifer
goes and shares a rumor that Melissa had
an affair and now nobody's going to feel
sorry for her ever again because that is
literally exactly what Margaret did to
her
no it's literally the same thing that
happened between like Teresa and Jackie
like Teresa brought up this Jackie
cheating thing like and she under the
guise of being like I have a son I heard
I didn't say anything and then um the
analogy it's like Teresa Teresa and
Jennifer are just immune to logic and
it's so frustrating to argue with people
like that yeah and like Danielle came on
the show and she was like you know what
I'm going up Teresa's ass like that was
clearly her emo I think she she's been
on reality TV before
this is her dream she saw it work out
for Jen what show was she on True Life
True Life I'm a Staten Island girl or
something like she wants to be a star
okay and you see that like with the way
she dresses her kids also extra that is
her attempt at being a star and I think
she wants to stay on the show for a
decent amount of time and she saw how it
worked out for Jen Aiden just like
immediately be lining for Teresa's
butthole and that's what she's doing and
I just like hate I just hate people like
that who don't like act on how they
truly feel or like what they think is
right they just like want to be on a
side yeah but I also can appreciate
someone coming and being like I have an
established relationship with Teresa
soil or Melissa because I think Rachel
food is somehow new Melissa she knew
team Logic for some reason and so you're
like inclined to believe them but like
you're open to all eventualities you
know but I honestly I think Rachel food
had an amazing first season I agree I'm
really enjoying her and her husband what
made me crack up is they waxed her
husband at Melissa's house and the whole
next day everyone's like are you okay
are you okay like people were worried
about him it's like women do that every
day in much more painful places yeah and
I don't have like team checking in
what's your thoughts by the way Dolores
it's like so interestingly like not on a
side and that's because she has the
brain of Team logic but the history with
Team not Logic for her yeah and she's
kind of like stayed out of it um but
what's your thoughts on the Frank of it
all okay Dolores is a hundred percent
right like 100 she gave Frank everything
for all of these years she like when she
was saying how the girls they used to
like make fun of her relationship with
David because he wasn't there for her
and like what's the future and this and
that and like now she has that
relationship and now they're like but
what about Frank when it's like when she
was with David like Frank was coming
around all the time and they're like but
where's David so it's like shut up you
guys said that you wanted this for me
the entire time I understand that Frank
is upset but it is dolores's turn in
life like she no and Paul's not wrong
Paul's not wrong all of Dolores it's sad
because like we love frank and everybody
loves Frank and Frank is Frank is hurt
but Frank is the star of the show but
like this is the first time in Frank's
life like where he can't have his cake
and eat it too but like typically for
regular people you can't have your cake
and eat it too so you know his his Good
Fortune ran out I'm sorry but it's
dolores's turn and she's a right I I
hope that I think that like Britney
should be more involved in like cast
stuff just so that Frank can come around
more but like yeah what Paul is asking
for is not crazy at all no not at all
it's not even like Dolores Mrs Frank
like you know she's not he's not like
Paul's asking her to do it and she's
like no she's not broken up about it no
she wants like a full life she finally
has a boyfriend who like wants her
completely and she doesn't need the
crutch of Frank to show up at events
with her yeah so as a Francophile of
course I want only what's best for him
no it just makes it more difficult now
because of the show yeah but I think
that they're the way that they're doing
it is gonna be fine because Frank is
like a guy friend and then even they
have that like couples night and
Brittany and Frank were there like and
Britney's friends with Jennifer Fuda so
I don't need her to be full-time but
just like when there's events Frank and
Brittany should be there and that works
for you yeah yeah yeah
um
so it's been a good season I mean i s we
both started the reunion [__] is so bad
between Melissa and Teresa and like now
everyone's like there's like a pretty
much a general consensus from the fandom
that Melissa's gonna be let go and fired
I don't think she will be like this is
now we're back to like 10 years ago the
whole cycle starts again of like them
all fighting the only my thing about
Melissa and Teresa obviously I'm more
team Melissa I think like Teresa even
when she Recaps her conversation that we
saw she'll recap at that conversation to
someone else I'm like you missed like
the actual points of the conversation
you just like heard when someone said
[__] you but like what were they
actually saying no a completely her
sense of reality is so distorted right
so it's like I'm not gonna take your
word for every other thing that you say
happened but okay
um but my
question mark is Louie I can't get a
read on him I don't know what his
intentions are because sometimes he's
The Peacemaker sometimes he is so
[__] rude to Teresa like not letting
her speak shutting her down making her
like listen to everyone and so true and
then other times he's you know gassing
her up and enabling her and making her
the worst version of herself like what
is he trying what position every now and
then he's like a true voice of reason
it's so weird like with Margaret like
any time he has so much respect for
Margaret and yes Teresa listen to her
but then he like flips when it's about
something else but even when he was
talking like Joe and Melissa he was like
weirdly putting Teresa down but then
when he's alone with Teresa he gathers
her up and then so she goes off on Joe
and Melissa and then Louie's like whoa
whoa right no no he has like multiple
personalities he's like psychotic I
can't understand him and his motives
right and I think that means his motives
are not good you know there's something
nefarious there but I can't identify it
I can't I can't say what he's trying to
do with her but I I imagine like for her
friend for her friends especially for
like Joe and Melissa it's like what the
[__] is this guy doing
it's scary yeah it's scary because he's
also like nice to them
no he's psychotic like that's how a
serial killer acts like how do you think
they lure people to their houses like
they're nice like what is he trying to
like what is his end game for Teresa and
her relationships I do not know no I
don't know it's [__] weird and like
the way that they all just talk about
therapy all the time like it's really a
bad endorsement for therapy
that's funny like seriously the worst
most dysfunctional couples are in
therapy telling all the good couples
that they have to go to therapy what to
do yeah yeah that's funny
um okay so that's our show we'll keep
you abreast I know you're gonna keep
watching that oh Love and Death really
quick I may only watch two episodes new
Max show starring Elizabeth Olsen and
Landry from Friday Night Lights oh
you'll follow him until the ends of the
Earth whose real name Jackie I refuse to
learn and I don't want to learn it it's
about it's apparently based on a true
story but I haven't been able to Google
it yet because I don't want to find out
how it ends
um but it's about like all these couples
living in like the 70s or 80s in Texas
like this conservative town like the
church is their life and two of the
couples like one of them starts to have
an affair with the other
um and I don't know how it goes sour but
like it clearly does but it's a very
good show like Elizabeth Olsen's an
amazing actress and her character is
like cute as a button and Landry's just
kind of this like oaf who like finds
himself having an affair with like a
much more beautiful woman and I don't
know where it goes but like someone he
ends up getting murdered and I don't
know who it is and the whole time I
think you're supposed to be figuring it
out who gets murdered who's the murderer
oh I'll watch
yeah no I think you'll like it it's also
just like really kind of beautifully
done the way they like paint like this
70s time in Texas it's like it's
adorable it's like aesthetically
pleasing oh and your favorite girl is in
there like Elizabeth Olsen's kind of
like Confidant and best friend is the
girl from Don't Trust the B Christopher
Chris Christian Ritter a man what's her
name I couldn't she doesn't have like a
starring role but I'd love to see her
out here like you know get it getting
booked and being busy also she's one of
those people it's like if she signs on
for something it's a good show
yeah she has like a high bar she's a
good picker or she just has good
I don't know luck it's only seven
minutes but it will get canceled once I
like it but I think it's a one season
kind of thing it tells the true story
and it's over afterwards that's a safe
Venture for me I think you would like it
I I so far I'm real and Ben is loving it
okay great I'm I'm influenced
um that's our show tomorrow we are in
studio with Taylor's Trekker so make
sure you catch that and we love you
dearly thanks so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show we love the
festival stories on YouTube please
subscribing this video thumbs up also
available
and wickedly talented we are have an
amazing day happy Monday don't forget to
rise and Grand and we'll see you
tomorrow yeah love you bye